and I used to be of the type that give
me the truth no matter what form it
comes but I've had some experiences
where I feel like sometimes the truth is
far too much for you to handle you can
damage yourself drastically from an
encounter with the truth and Lovecraft
had this this quote the greatest Mercy
in the world is the inability for the
human mind to correlate its contents and
that one day we'll see that this
unfettered scientific investigation may
bring about such a terrifying Vista of
real
that we'll see our fragile place in it
and be so frightened that we'll either
go mad from the Revelation
or or flee from the light into the peace
and security of the Dark Ages